the united states supreme court decision
to overturn roe versus wade ended a
constitutional right women across
america have had for nearly four decades
the right to choose an abortion the
reproductive rights of an estimated 58
million women were called into question
and the status of abortion rights across
america became fractured from state to
state this is the story in four charts
hours after the supreme court handed
down their judgment missouri became the
first state to ban abortion
thirteen states had trigger laws ready
laws passed in anticipation of this
moment
in the days that followed the picture of
abortion rights across the states was
constantly changing
places like south carolina and south
dakota banned the procedure
but judges in some states including west
virginia and louisiana temporarily block
these bans some of which are still yet
to be
enforced
so what's the state of abortion access
across america today well things are
moving fast than in a dramatic
referendum in kansas voters have
rejected a plan to ban abortion it's the
first referendum there will be many more
and the biden administration has brought
its first legal case it's against idaho
over its planned total ban idaho's law
violates the supremacy clause of the
united states constitution abortion is
banned right now in 16 states and legal
in 27 others then there are the states
where it's legal for now but bans are
expected there are two types of abortion
medical and surgical medical abortions
involve taking two tablets prescribed by
a health care provider over a specific
time frame and crucially they could be
taken in the comfort of your own home
more and more women have chosen medical
abortions in recent years particularly
during the coveit pandemic the latest
data from may 2022 shows they accounted
for more than half of abortions across
the united states
now with the overturning of roe medical
abortions are expected to play an even
bigger role one telemedicine provider
hey jane experienced a 107 percent
increase in web visitors since the
supreme court's decision and nearly a
fifth more patients what's unclear
though is the legality some states
including indiana and texas have
expressly banned medical abortions but
whether providers working across states
with different abortion laws can be and
will be prosecuted well that remains to
be seen
so who is most affected by roe being
overturned there are an estimated 58
million women of reproductive age in the
united states at the latest count and
according to the latest figures here's a
breakdown of the demographics of who has
an abortion
if you're a woman in your twenties
you're part of the group most likely to
have an abortion they make up nearly
two-thirds of the total numbers
[Music]
in terms of ethnicity non-hispanic black
women make up the largest group and
they're closely followed by white women
we can also break down the data by
whether these women already had children
and 60 percent did
watch now for the political
repercussions the midterm elections are
in november pro-choice democrats hope
they'll get a boost from voters who
think the republicans have shifted too
far right
[Applause]
the picture though is fractured the
challenges for women in states across
the nation are huge part of america's
social fabric has been unwoven